[Music]
voting for adults one of the few
remaining activities for it you still
get a sticker the midterm elections are
just two months away when every citizen
of voting age will have their chance to
be heard even this guy thing is the
category and when you're ready Edgar
fish love this law sorry Edgar but the
category was things are the answer we
were looking for was fish loop it's it's
the thing you use when you want to
a fish facially but a lot next time
Edgar the fact is while that fish pucker
may be able to cast the votes a
surprisingly large amount of people are
barred from doing so it's estimated that
more than six million Americans are
barred from voting because of felony
disenfranchisement laws it's true six
million people are unable to vote
because at some point in their life they
committed a felony that is a lot for
perspective that's like if you took all
the people who bought a copy of Robin
Thicke's divorce opera Paula and then
added almost six million more people
look if any of you are thinking this
point well who really gives a if
convicted felons can't vote you frankly
wouldn't be alone they've committed
crimes are they the best people to judge
some of these laws that are to be passed
would we rather live in a society where
there are no consequences for our
actions I just think that they've done
something wrong so I don't really think
they should be allowed to be voting in
our president and stuff like that oh oh
you don't do you you think if someone
makes a mistake you should follow them
for the rest of their life whether they
were convicted of marijuana possession
or went to brunch dressed like a TJ Maxx
Janis Joplin I get it I get it the fact
here is many lawmakers actually agree
with her here is Mitch McConnell arguing
that keeping felons from voting is a
public safety issue we're talking about
rapists murderers and robbers and even
terrorists or spies do we want to see
convicted terrorists who seek to destroy
this country voting in elections
okay first terrorists are not voting are
they they're all about making giant
violent points that get everyone's
attention not lining up in a public
school gymnasium to write in Isis for
this
school boards and second the most recent
analysis found only 18% of felony
convictions were for violent crimes of
any sort meaning the vast majority were
for nonviolent offenses like property or
drug crimes and for those who have
served their sentence but are still
unable to vote this situation is
understandably frustrating at what point
do we break the cycle at what point are
we able to say hey you know what
I am citizen enough you want me to work
you want me to pay taxes you want me to
make sure I take care of my family but
yeah I can't vote so am i citizen or am
I not a citizen yeah he's got a point
because that man is suffering taxation
without representation and historically
that's been a bit of a sticking point
for America I'm pretty sure I learned
about that in school something about the
American savages through tea into the
water without even having the common
decency to add a splash of milk so so
tonight so tonight let's look at felony
disenfranchisement and one state in
particular because these six million
disenfranchised voters are not evilly
distributed around the country in most
states people with felony convictions
automatically regain their voting rights
at some point but there are a few where
they do not and the worst state of all
concerning this and arguably everything
else is Florida around one and a half
million of its citizens nearly 10% of
its adult population have completed
sentences for felony convictions but
still can't vote and given the
iniquities of our justice system that
burden is disproportionately felt by
african-americans because in Florida
over one in five black adults cannot
vote that is staggering it may be the
dumbest thing about Florida which is
frankly impressive considering stories
like these only in Florida would an
underwear clad man go for a walk in the
rain with his pet goat also if you could
tell there he's um he's playing a
harmonica check out this video showing a
genius steering his motorcycle with his
feet in Jacksonville only in Florida
does a creature this adorable become a
bloodthirsty fur demon all of a sudden
he jumped on the kayak in two seconds
later he jumped on me the viral video
shows Robbie Stratton running through a
convenience store with an alligator in
his hands no wreck
action of that happening at all at all
this store sells a good liquor okay
everything about that guy is absolutely
fascinating but I think I'm most
interested to the fact that he was drunk
at the store where he bought the liquor
so did he buy the liquor leave drinking
fetch an alligator and then returned to
the same store did he drink the liquor
at the store at which point an alligator
walked in or did he get drunk and then
meet a sober alligator was having a bad
day once it have a couple of drinks and
the guy said I know just the place
alligator I don't know the point is it's
Florida all options are equally
plausible here's the thing the fact is
Florida is the disenfranchisement
capital of America so how did that
happen well for starters a post-civil
war changed their constitution stripped
all convicted felons of their voting
rights for life
and while Florida's governor can restore
those rights the current one Rick Scott
seen here auditioning for the role of
happy pencil in all my nightmares he has
made this process much more difficult
because what the governor before him
made regaining voting rights close to
automatic for many nonviolent offenses
Scott implemented a system where you
have to wait five to seven years just to
apply to get your vote back then submit
an application then wait more then in
many cases have to travel to Tallahassee
which no one should ever have to do
under any circumstances to argue your
case in person these obstacles are
ridiculous and unnecessary and this is
how Scott justified them look if you if
you are a convicted felon and part of
what you did you lost your rights and so
you ought to you know there ought to be
a process if you're gonna get those
rights back and I think it's fair to the
rest of the citizens of the state and
it's they'll see a process that they
didn't they know will work right except
there is a process for paying your debt
to society and getting your rights back
it's called
serving your sentence you're
just tagging on at the end it's
like someone finishing a triathlon and
we can start to then say no it's a
quarter con now you have to learn manual
it doesn't really seem fair and and it's
honestly worth taking a look at this
process because it's absolutely insane
applications are judged by a clemency
board made up of Rick Scott and members
of his cabinet seen here looking like
the only local news team that you
somehow know aren't each other
and and if you do end up in front of me
you're given ten minutes to prove that
you have turned your life around
they then question you before making a
decision that seems completely arbitrary
and it seems that way because it is
Scott begins meetings by making that pre
fully clear this is a board of clemency
okay we there's no law we're following
the law are been followed by the judges
so we get to make our decisions based on
our own beliefs there's no standards
each of us have the right opportunity
make a decision the way based on what we
believe this is this is a court of mercy
it's not a court in this if there's no
when if you walk up and say I deserve
something that's not how this works
we this there's no there's absolutely no
standards so we can make any decisions
we want you know I'm sure that's true
it's just weird to hear it set out loud
in the same way that would be weird to
give the CEO of Kraft say we don't
actually know what Velveeta is it fell
from space in the 1950s and it's been
spawning in a lab ever since before we
package it we take out the teeth and ice
but we're starting to think it might
make it angry and look because there are
no formal standards the committee can
decide what's important and can focus on
things as petty as moving violations
what we're trying to figure out is is
that have people change their lives
right right that's so so getting traffic
tickets all the time so if you sit up
here your first reaction as well do they
really respect the law right right I
mean that might be your first reaction
to be honest my first reaction is why
rick scott's glass is not near the eyes
part of his head and how have they not
fallen off his nose by now
it is not just your driving record under
scrutiny your personal life is very much
on the table and one board member
Florida CFO Jimmy Patronus seems to have
a specific idea of where that personal
life should be conducted because there
is one question that he asks a lot y'all
go to church you go to church you go to
church together
ma'am where do y'all go to church go
Church and go to church do you go to
church now if the answer to that
question is important that is up
and if it's not why are you constantly
asking it either you are factoring
religious habit into your evaluation of
whether someone should be able to vote
or you're making a list of people's
houses that would be easy to rob on a
Sunday morning and neither is a good use
of the panel's time and once you've
jumped through all of these hoops your
fate is in the hands of a panel who do
not have to explain their reasoning to
you just watch Leon Gillis he had served
time for robbery and drug convictions
but had been clean for eight years and
was running a drug rehab program when he
made his case to the board in 2011 Rick
Scott actually commended him for the
progress that he'd made and then said
this so at this point I'm gonna deny in
restoration of civil rights and can I
answer your question yes sir
how long is there I'm not sure and you
know I think every key every case is
different if I'm doing everything I'm
supposed to do and I'm trying and I'm
making sure that I do the right thing
I'm supposed to do then how long am I
supposed to wait I can tell you that in
that answer but if today and not I don't
feel comfortable doing it okay thank you
and that was it he refused to restore
someone's civil rights without
demonstrating much more of a reason than
I don't know I guess I'm just not
feeling it right now and the thing is
even if this process was perfect which
it is not it can't handle the volume
that the panel only makes meets four
times a year and there are too many
cases for them to review also while
Scott's predecessor restored the Voting
Rights of over one hundred and fifty
five thousand people in his four-year
term Scott is only averaging around 400
a year and that is meaningful especially
in a state where elections tend to have
very narrow margins Trump only won
Florida by a hundred thousand
folks and President Bush famously won it
by just 537 but there are actually
there's actually some genuinely good
news here Florida has a chance to fix
this a real chance there was a
constitutional amendment on their ballot
this November
that would bring Florida in line with
many other states if it passes people
with felony convictions except in the
cases of murder or sex crimes would get
the right to vote after completing their
sentence that could give as many as 1.4
million people the right to vote but it
is by no means a foregone conclusion the
amendment needs a 60% majority to pass
so if it's okay with everybody I would
like to speak directly to the people of
Florida for a second
hi there Florida let's let's try to get
comfortable with each other shall we
I know that we make I know that we make
fun fun of you a lot Florida because of
all the stupid things that happen where
you live and you'll probably expected me
to steer away from all that and appeal
to your innate goodness and sense of
reason but I'm not going to do that
instead
I'd like to Double Down and suggest that
it's precisely because of all that
glorious stupidity that you should
innately appreciate the value of second
chances I mean come on Florida your
Florida a state that's seen the
headlines Florida restaurant no longer
allows monkey Mondays after animal bit
eight-year-old boy and Florida besties
allottee law does not ban oral sex with
animals and Florida gas station dropped
suspect appeared to have drawn on beards
which I would say is probably true given
that this was the beard and yes yes
Floridians you do make mistakes but it's
also in your nature to help one another
recover as you can tell from the
headline Good Samaritan helps Florida
man who accidentally shot himself in the
penis you can't throw for each other
even this song your state song speaks to
your ability to screw up and bounce back
the original lyrics did this have to be
changed because they were too racist and
somehow it still sounds racist today
even in instrumental form the point here
is there's November Florida you have got
a real chance to remedy a mistake and do
something genuinely good for over a
million of your citizens so please on
November 6th for one day just one day
don't take your goat for a walk in your
underwear stay away from any bitey
otters draw a fake beard on yourself and
go cast a vote on behalf of all your
fellow Floridians who are unable to
please do it Cheers Florida Cheers
[Music]
you